what do you think I should name this yep
Pretty Little Liars star che Mitchell's
got a pretty little baby on the way the
32 year old first announced the exciting
pregnancy news on Instagram with this
ultra glam pic then in a YouTube video
spam in YouTube kind of a tie so yeah I
try and use a little bit on each of the
problems just I can stay up with it with
the kids they say the clip also serves
as an announcement for a new youtuber
docu-series about her pregnancy it
didn't feel right to just put up a photo
and be like I'm pregnant and have people
just think that everything has been
peaches and rainbows this is real life
and I want people to come along with me
on this journey in real time the baby's
father is featured in the trailer he's
Matt Babel a Canadian TV host he and
Shay have been quietly dating for years
and it seems the pair's been keeping the
baby secret for a while while explaining
how she's been covering up her bump in
the teaser a shot of Shay and an Oscars
party pops up that would have been back
in February this will be the first child
for Shay and Matt they experienced a
miscarriage in 2018 which Shay opened up
about on Instagram I respect her bravery
so much that can't be an easy thing to
talk about and a lot of people go
through that and I think that that she
can you know kind of inspire people for
the hope of you know life still going on
and still amazing things still happening
[Music]